she was standing in the middle of the
room all eyes weren't her and then she
started singing a song about love hope
and resurrection a song that summarized
her life how she grew up in the south as
a daughter of a mixed-race couple how
she moved to Africa and found the man of
her dreams and how she was working Haiti
where she survived a tragic earthquake
and hearing all of this I had tears in
my eyes and after she finished the whole
room about a hundred of our classmates
bursted into applause this was not just
any speech
this was her talk talk is a weekly
tradition here at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business where classmates
share their life stories in 30-minute
talks every Monday and Wednesday evening
the whole class comes together in a room
this size and listens to two of our
classmates stories stories about their
lies and their lows of their lives
stories about love hope resurrection
so if you had 30 minutes to talk about
your life what would you talk about Oh
be your story my name is Claudia and I'm
a second year student here at Stanford
and I'm one of the official coaches for
the people want to give a talk and my
passion is to help others find their
story and today I want to share with you
how you can find your story as well
because knowing your story is powerful
but what I mean by story your story is
who you are and what you stand for
it's your values and your beliefs it's
your past experiences and your
aspirations
it's your dreams and your fears and
knowing your story is important because
it can help you figure out what you're
passionate about and it can help you
find inspiration that keep you running
and difficult times and it can also help
you answer a difficult question like
what job do you want to work for or what
type of leader do you want to be and I
see that power every week and the people
who give a talk so let me tell you a
little bit about my story growing up I
wasn't the most popular kid I was very
nerdy very insecure and I didn't really
have a lot of friends and it took me
quite a while to overcome those
insecurities but knowing where I started
and the development that I made the
story behind me gives me a deep care for
people in a similar situation and and it
also inspired me to become a coach and
so no matter how many hours I spent
coaching people or how many hours I
spent helping people for the talk I know
why I care about it I know why it's
important to me now finding your story
is difficult it's scary it's frustrating
and it takes time
and you might look at all the people who
have given successful tapas and might
think wow they figured it out they know
exactly what their story is well I would
tell you most of the top coaching
sessions don't want to start that way
most of the talkers they come to the
first session in the same everyone else
has a great story but I don't yet they
all make it food and develop an
inspiring story themselves and you might
think the same of low keynotes
you've seen some fantastic speeches
today and you might think as well wow
they figured it out they know exactly
what their story is but let me give you
a dilemma see I hide the curtain we've
not always been so sure about our story
I have not always been so sure about my
story three weeks ago I gave this speech
at the official rehearsal and I
completely bombed it if you have refer
to speech I could feel that it was not
working I was mumbling my words might
might my thoughts don't came across the
way I wanted it and I completely fell
apart it was bad
in fact so bad that when two speakers or
two coaches gave me feedback I started
crying I was really devastated I was
thinking about quitting my speech but
then I thought again and instead of
quitting my speech I reminded myself
that developing your story is difficult
and I want to share with you free
learnings I had for my time as a top
coach if L oak up top coach of mine
who's actually guru today once compared
the process of finding your story with
the process of cleaning your room and if
you look at it firm for it at first you
when you think about cleaning your room
you don't really want to do it because
it's messy these time and you wanna want
to watch another episode of Mad Men
and one to actually do it and you take
everything out of your closet and your
drawer and place it on the bed and on
the floor and you would look at your
room in that very moment you would
realize that it looks actually a lot
messier than you looked before but
that's the first learning embrace the
missus don't be scared if the process
feels uncomfortable the messiness is
part of the process and second think
about why every single piece of your
life is important to you to take
everything that you have on your bed and
think about why do I care about this and
don't throw away something because ours
might not like it
for example the gift from your grandma
that you really care about but it looks
serious because it's your room it's your
story and you get to decide what's in it
and third think about how two different
pieces relate to each other so how the
hideous gift of your grandma really
reminds you of the metal that you want
in college because your story or in your
life is not different separate stories
it's one whole story and once you talk
about all of these things you're ready
to put everything that you have back
into the place where it belongs and
you're right you're ready to share your
room and your story with the world so
after my rather messy first rehearsal I
thought about again like what what what
why is this important for me and how
does this story here rage in my life and
then he clicked because I thought of you
and you and you
I want you to quit your speech I don't
want you to withhold your story I want
you to stay silent so if you had 30
minutes to talk about your life what
would you talk about and I want to give
you homework today think about one thing
in your life that has been very
important for you and share it with
someone else but and of today and
Vermont remember to free lessons embrace
the messiness so don't worry if it's not
perfect think about why this story is so
important for you and think about how to
rest of your life
relate to it and always remember knowing
your story is powerful thank you